okay it's uh
five o'clock hopefully wow where i am
two o'clock in california um
welcome back everybody and uh it's a
pleasure to introduce mary wooders
from stanford university and she's going
to
finish the afternoon session with her
talk on sharp thresholds for random
subspaces
please go ahead thanks um yeah thanks
for the invitation and uh thanks assad
for the introduction
um yeah it's really great to get to talk
to you guys today um so yeah i'm going
to talk about
sharp thresholds for random subspaces
with some applications to coding theory
um and this is based on joint work with
uh jonathan mosheff
nick resh nogaranzui and joshua silas
okay so what does this talk about um so
the
title has some coding theory jargon in
it but basically what this talk is about
is it's about combinatorial properties
of random subspaces over finite fields
right so i'm just going to take like a
uniformly random subspace over some
finite field
it's a bunch of points it's a discrete
thing and i'm wondering what sorts of
commentarial properties does this bunch
of points satisfy
so for example is it the case that no
hamming ball contains too many of these
points
um something like that uh and there are
some applications to these
types of properties i'm interested in
they come from error correcting codes
but
hopefully what i have to say will be of
interest even if you are not into error
correcting codes um
hopefully these are just sort of
interesting probability questions
um so the plan for the talk is i'm going
to give a quick
intro to what sorts of combinatorial
properties i'm interested in
and a little bit about why i'm
interested in them although not too much
and then i'm going to tell you a
threshold theorem
for what properties are satisfied with
high probability by uniformly random
subspaces
so basically for these sorts of
properties that i'm interested in like
not having too many points contained in
any hamming ball it's going to be the
case that as the dimension of the
subspace goes from small to large
uh like very large subspaces are very
unlikely to satisfy these properties
like there'd be tons of points in some
hamming ball
very low dimensional subspaces are quite
likely to satisfy these properties
and i'm kind of interested in like what
is the threshold in between like what is
the point where
uh you know a subspace goes from being
very likely to being very unlikely to
satisfy such a property and i'll tell
you that there is a sharp threshold
uh turns out for a certain very broad
class of properties um and
also i can give you a characterization
of that threshold um so that will sort
of be the second part of the talk
and the third part of the talk is an
application of this uh characterization
um to ldpc or low density parity check
codes
um but from a probability perspective
the punch line of this application is
basically that you can
transfer concentration of measure type
results that you would be able to prove
for uniformly random subspaces that you
can basically transfer those almost for
free
to uh more structured random subspaces
or at least to a particular distribution
of more structured random subspaces
and that's basically going to fall out
for free from this um characterization
threshold theorem um that we'll see
okay so that's the basic plan um let me
get started
by telling you just about random
subspaces and a few nice properties that
they might satisfy
um so what are the sorts of questions
that i'm interested in
okay so first random subspaces of our
finite fields like what what do i mean
by that
um so uh throughout this talk this
blackboard bold f here is going to
denote a finite field
um if it's been a while since finite
fields uh don't don't worry it's fine if
you just want to think about this as
being f2 so that is just
zero and one with arithmetic mod two
that'll be fine for almost all of the
talk
um so just just think about f as being
f2 if you like or any finite field
and i'm interested in subspaces over
this finite field f
so subspaces v that are subsets of f to
the n
and here subspaces over a finite field i
just mean the same thing as subspaces
over the reals just some set that's
closed under addition and scalar
multiplication
so just a quick example to make sure
we're on the same page like here's an
example of a subspace
of f2 to the six of dimension two i take
uh two basis vectors um so each of these
basis vectors is a binary vector of
length six and then i look at their span
so this their span contains zero the
first basis vector the second basis
vector
and then there's some mod two so this is
going to be my subspace it has size four
okay so the reason or one reason that
i'm being so pedantic about what do i
mean by a random subspace
is uh for the rest of this talk i'm
going to draw
subspaces over a finite field by this
cartoon here
um so the the points here are meant to
indicate that it's some kind of discrete
finite set and the little picture of a
plane
in r3 is meant to indicate that there's
some type of linear structure
um so that's what this cartoon means but
this is like extremely misleading about
the geometry like they don't look like
this don't don't think they look like
this they think they look like this
so the reason i did this example is just
to emphasize you should be thinking
about these things as like subsets of
the hypercube not
like this but i'm going to draw them
like this anyway
okay so that's a random subspace of
that's those are subspaces over finite
fields i'm interested in
random subspaces here when i say random
subspace i'm going to mean uniformly
random subspace
and so a uniformly random subspace over
a finite field is just a
uniformly random subspace over a finite
field so there's finitely many of them
just just take a uniformly random one
cool okay so now that we know what we're
talking about uniformly random subspaces
over finite fields we can ask some
questions about them
um so here are a few questions that you
might ask question one
what is the closest that any two points
in v can be to each other
in hamming distance so here hamming
distance the hamming distance between
two vectors x and y
is just the number of coordinates on
which they differ
so i can ask out of all of the points in
this
subspace like look at every single pair
of points look at how far apart they
they are from each other
like uh what's the closest any two of
them can be and in particular is it the
case that with high probability
none of them are too close so that's one
sort of question you might want to ask
another sort of question in a similar
vein is what is the maximum number of
points of my
subspace v that lie in any hamming ball
of radius p
n um so here i don't mean in any fixed
hamming ball but kind of like a worst
case hamming ball so i'll draw my random
subspace
and then i'll take my hamming ball and
i'll kind of like move it all around the
subspace and try to capture as many
points as possible
um and uh my question is like when i do
this what is the maximum number of
points that i can capture
so that's some random variable depends
on the randomness of my subspace
and again i want to maybe maybe be able
to make some statement like
you know as long as the dimension is not
too big with high probability
uh probably no hamming ball will capture
too many points something like that
okay uh another question you might want
to ask i could just go on all day
uh like i could replace the hamming ball
with some combinatorial rectangle like
uh
s1 cross s2 cross dot dot cross sn
where each s i is a subset of my finite
field of psi is not too big
here this is the one example where you
you should not think of f as being f2
but maybe some bigger finite field
and again i can ask the same question
like what is the maximum number of
points of my random subspace v
that live in any one of these
combinatorial rectangles if i just like
look at all of the possible ones
and again hopefully i could make some
statement of the form with high
probability there are not too many
points in any combinatorial rectangle
okay so those are a bunch of questions
you can ask why
might you ask these questions uh well i
kind of think they're interesting on
their own right um you know just in in
their own right uh
as math questions but my original
motivation for studying these comes from
error correcting codes
um so i'm not going to go into this uh
very much at all but just one one slide
to maybe wave my hands a little bit
about why i might care about these
questions
um so this first question that i talked
about the distance between any two
points this is actually a very
classically studied question
in the theory of error correcting codes
another way to say this question is just
what is the distance of a random linear
code
um so here code just means subset of f
to the n
and so random linear code means random
linear subspace of f
q to the n of f to the n so this is like
exactly what we're studying
and distance just means uh you know the
minimum distance between any two points
so this is a very classical notion that
people are interested in encoding theory
super briefly one reason why is that
imagine you're like using these points
here for communication
so to each of these points i'm going to
associate a message and i'm going to
want to send this message across some
noisy channel
if the points are all really far apart
then if there's a little bit of noise
let's say i want to send this point and
it gets perturbed a little bit
then if they're all really far apart i
can sort of round back to the
to the point i was interested in i can
like correct the noise so that's the
basic idea behind an error correcting
code
and so it's an interesting question to
ask like what is the distance of such a
set
the second question about hamming balls
this is basically
asking what is the list decodability of
a random linear code
so list decodability again is a
classical notion in coding theory and
the the basic idea here is that
um any particular hamming ball of a
fixed radius
might represent uh in this communication
setting that i said before might
represent like
the set of points you might plausibly be
confused about like i didn't know which
one the sender meant to send
and if you can show that not too many
points live in any such ball you can
sort of limit
the amount of confusion that you get at
the end of the at the end of the day
um similarly this question that i asked
about combinatorial rectangles this also
has a name encoding theory it's called
list recoverability
the motivation is basically the same
under a different error model um this
combinatorial rectangle is like the set
of things you might get confused about
and if there are not too many points in
your subspace that live in the
commentary rectangle then
like hooray you don't you don't get
confused so that's why you might uh be
asking these questions if you comment
things from a coding theory background
um which i do um and why you might be
asking them about random linear codes in
particular or these like random
subspaces in particular
uh well actually for for some of these
questions uh
just for existential results it's you
know if you want to make an existential
result like there exists a
linear code with good distance you know
random linear code is a pretty good
place to start
um and also for that same reason they're
uh they can be useful in constructions
like you take a really little random
linear code that gives you like the best
existential thing you know and then
you can sort of use that as a building
block in some bigger
more efficient construction um okay so
these questions uh come up i'm not going
to say too much more about
why one cares but um if you're
interested in you know please ask me
after the talk
and uh for now let's just forget about
the motivation and just like focus on
these questions like what properties do
random subspaces satisfy
okay so uh what do we know about these
questions
so uh like i said these questions have
been studied for a while in the context
of coding theory so by now we know a lot
so here's a real quick lit review about
these three questions in particular
so this first question how far apart are
any two points in a random subspace um
like i said it's a very classical
question and the answer to it
um or at least one one side of the
answer to it is called the gilbert
varsimov bound so here's here's what we
know
so here on the x-axis uh i'm drawing the
rate
of the code um or sorry the dimension of
the subspace um so here's some some
jargon
uh instead of measuring the dimension of
the subspace i'm going to normalize it
by the dimension of the ambient space so
i'm going to be looking at this
fraction k over n so subspace dimension
divided by ambient dimension
and i'm going to call this the the rate
um encoding theory language that's the
sort of the communication rate of the
code um and so here i have the dimension
of the subspace
on the x-axis so up here uh i have like
the full
the full-dimensional subspace just the
whole thing all of f to the n and down
here i just have the trivial subspace
just zero
and on the y axis i have the probability
that a random k dimensional subspace
um satisfies this property that i'm
interested in in this case that it has
distance at least delta
okay all pairs of points are at least
delta n apart
and what we know is that there is some
special threshold uh
in the in the dimension of the code so
if i back off
by a little bit from that threshold so
if i look at a subspace of dimension
just a little bit less
then with super high probability i'm
going to satisfy this this property
aka there's going to be no pair of
points that's too close to each other
all pairs of points are going to be far
apart
on the other hand if i go a little bit
above that threshold so i have a
slightly higher dimensional subspace
then all of a sudden it becomes
extremely likely that i do not
satisfy this property that is that there
are two points that are really close
together
okay so that's uh sort of what's known
for for this question and again this is
a
sort of a pretty uh classical result
it's not not too hard to say you could
probably
do it yourself um if you get bored later
okay how about the next question uh how
many points lie in any hamming ball
this turns out to be a lot more tricky
there's
still ongoing work on it there's still
things we don't know but the basic
cartoon
looks roughly the same there's some
threshold rate
and if you back off from that by a
little bit so you look at a slightly
lower dimensional subspace
and with really high probability you'll
satisfy this property not too many
points will be in any hamming wall
um and if you go a little bit above that
so you look at a slightly higher
dimensional subspace
then with really high probability you're
not going to satisfy this property
there's going to be some hamming ball
that has tons of points in it
so same same basic picture and we can
ask
the same question what's known about
points that live
sort of in a combinatorial rectangle
once again
uh this is actually an even more open
question we don't quite have everything
pinned down but if you zoom way out the
the basic cartoon looks roughly the same
there's some threshold rate
if you back off by a little bit um then
uh with really high probability
the property is satisfied and if you go
a little bit above that with really high
probability the
property is not satisfied
okay so the story so far this is all
just kind of introduction stuff
um i asked you uh three questions about
random subspaces uh over finite fields
and i told you a little bit that they
were motivated by coding theory and i
told you that they all have
sharp thresholds um so that's sort of
the
background and i'm gonna go forward from
here but before i move on
are there any questions
i have a quick question mary so i think
you mentioned it before so so far
the results you mentioned uh hold for
f2 to the n or they're typical for any
finite field
um for any finite field um yeah well so
this one doesn't even make sense over f2
actually like here you need a large
enough field
um yeah and these ones
this certainly works over any field this
depending on the parameter regime works
over some fields better than
others and larger ones get a little more
dicey um but uh yeah
there are results of this flavor over
lots of fields
thanks more questions
uh what is h of b oh sorry uh
h of p down here this is the entropy of
p
so p times log one over p plus one minus
p times log uh
one over one minus p um for binary codes
uh
over larger fields replace this with the
q area entropy which is
roughly the same thing but base q sorry
about that
yeah the actual the identity of this
threshold is not going to be super
important
for this talk the main thing i wanted
you to take away from this is that it
has this kind of threshold behavior
in the last um picture about
the rectangle you drew the curve a
little differently is that meant to
indicate
something uh yeah i guess i i i mean
these are all
curves that i drew by hand and
powerpoint so don't take um
they're not uh meant to be very precise
but yeah
i drew this one like scaled a little bit
out to indicate that we don't
the answers that we have are a little
bit less tight for this question
in particular there's a lot more wiggle
room and like what
what should um what should this number
be like how many points live in a
should live in a a combinatorial
rectangle um
we can say some constant depending on l
what is the dependence on l uh
other questions is that uh really
sharp in all respects so for example if
i wanted to ask the question the same
question about the cubes but saying
when when does it happen that 90 of the
possible cubes
will contain if i relax that way is it
the same kind of threshold i see that's
a good question
um
that is studied and i
believe you can do
better in in that situation i don't have
the results off the top of my head
though
so maybe ask me again later and i can do
a quick review and get back to you
cool okay so i guess let me move ahead
to um
the the the new stuff though so it's not
to get um
sort of bogged down in the background um
yeah but so this is the story so far and
again the main takeaways that i wanted
you to take from those previous slides
are that
uh all of these three questions um like
to the extent that we know the answer
they look basically like this
um so for the rest of the talk what i'm
gonna do is
first i'm gonna tell you that this
threshold behavior
is a very general phenomenon um and uh
in particular it holds for any local
property where local property is
something i have to define
um moreover i'm going to give you a
characterization
of this threshold so i will tell you
like you tell me something about the
property i'll tell you something about
the threshold
and the third part of the talk uh is an
application um like i said some
application to list decoding ldpc codes
but uh the sort of intuitive punchline
is that basically it's
carrying over some of these properties
from the uniformly random case
to the not uniformly random case so ldpc
codes um
which i'll define later in the talk if i
have time are
basically give us some structured very
structured ensemble of random subspaces
and uh what this third part of the talk
is going to be showing is that
if you have like a high probability
result like these results up here
for uniformly random codes so this says
that um
you know with high probability a random
linear code uh sorry not uniformly a
random linear code will will satisfy um
this property your uniformly random
subspace will satisfy this property
then with high probability this
structured random subspace will also
satisfy the property
so just a quick aside um to kind of
insert the concentration of measure
angle here because this is a workshop
about concentration of measure
um basically what this is doing is
allowing us to translate concentration
of measure results from one setting to
another
so like these results up here are
concentration of measure results
basically
you want to show that um you know
certain properties hold with high
probability uh in some random object
and the way these these are are proved
um you know use a lot of concentration
of measure techniques so lots of tail
but
lots of tail bounds um chaining
arguments stuff like that
um and essentially what we're going to
be able to do is transfer these
concentration of measure results
to uh a more structured ensemble where
there's even less randomness and we'll
kind of get to do this for free from our
uh
uh threshold there cool okay so that's
sort of the outline
um so let me get started with uh
sharp thresholds for local properties so
what do i mean by a local property and
um
what is this threshold theorem okay so
what is a local property
so uh basically intuitively a local
property is defined by the exclusion of
bad
sets um so a little more formally
suppose that curly b
is a collection of bad sets b1 b2 and so
on
subsets of f to the n so the following
things hold
first i want b to be invariant under
coordinate permutations
um so let me illustrate that with an
example so here's like a possible
collection of bad sets here so these are
bad sets of size two that live in f2 to
the four
um so here are like the dark squares are
meant to be ones and the light squares
are meant to be zeros i guess
uh and this set curly b is invariant
under coordinate permutations because
like if i look at this
set b1 and i permute the coordinates
let's say i switch
the second coordinate and the third
coordinate here and then i'm going to
get
um looks like b3 right and
similarly if i take any of these and i
do any coordinate permutation i'm going
to always stay within this set
so that's the first thing the second
thing is that uh each of these bad sets
b
has size at most little b um
so in this case little b is just two
okay so suppose i have this collection
of bad sets curly b that satisfies these
properties
then a b local property these are the
sorts of properties i'm interested in
are going to be properties of the form
there is no bad set that is contained in
my
subspace so that's the definition of a b
local property
so in this example it's like if i take a
random subspace
uh of f 2 to the 4 and i ask like
the corresponding b local property that
corresponds to this particular bad set
curly b
is the property that none of these pairs
of points are contained in this subspace
or equivalently there is no x and y uh
in my subspace so that x is the negation
of y and x where it has weight two
which is just another way of describing
this um silly little set
curly b okay so that's what a local
property is
um that might seem like a funny
definition but
um actually we've already seen three
examples of it all three of my earlier
examples are local properties so
distance at least
delta n is defined by the exclusion of
pairs of points that are too close to
each other
list decodability is defined by the
exclusion of
i guess l tuples of points that all live
in a hamming wall
and list recoverability is defined by
the exclusion again of l tuples of
points that all live in some
combinatorial rectangle
um so this is a i'd like to argue this
is a pretty natural notion and it covers
sort of all of the
the coding theoretic motivation that
i mentioned earlier okay so with that
definition
here's this threshold theorem that i
promised um
so the theorem basically says that for
any local property you're going to get
this diagram that we had earlier
so formally suppose that epsilon is
greater than zero for any v
local property p sub curly b on f to the
n
there's some threshold r star right here
so that if you back off a little bit
from r star then you'll satisfy
the property uh with probability one
minus the low of one
if you go forward you'll satisfy the
prob you will if you go forward by
epsilon so you'll get a slightly higher
dimensional subspace
then with probability one minus the low
of one you will not satisfy the property
okay so this threshold thing is uh it's
pretty general
um i think the more interesting thing
though is that we can actually give a
characterization
of this threshold so let me uh
make i'm going to introduce this
characterization kind of by example and
in order to do so i'm also going to make
a couple of simplifying assumptions
um so let's let's just assume that each
one of our bad sets
has size exactly little b and also has
dimension exactly
little b um so in this case each of
these uh
bad sets has size exactly two and also
dimension actually
exactly two um in this case just these
two points are these two vectors are
linearly independent
um let's also just for ease of drawing
things assume that the size of f is two
and let's also assume that curly b
contains only one orbit under coordinate
permutation
so all of these assumptions can be
removed um it's just going to make the
exposition a little bit easier so
basically we're just assuming that the
situation looks like this this
little toy example curly bead that i had
before
okay so we would like to uh try to
figure out like what is the threshold
at which i become really likely to
contain one of these bad sets
so the first thing we might try is a
first moment attempt
right so we have some random
k-dimensional subspace of f2 to the n
and we want to upper bound the
probability that there exists
some bad set in my subspace so a very
natural thing to do first is like let's
just compute the expected number of bad
sets that live in my subspace
and if that expected number is little o
of one then by markups inequality
i probably won't have a bad set in my
subspace all right so let's just try
that
see how well that works okay so let's do
the computation so for some fixed bad
set what's the probability that that bad
set is contained in my subspace
uh well i claim that it's it's this
thing um
2 to the k divided by 2 to the n so this
here is
this is the probability that a single
point is contained in my random subspace
because there's 2 to the k
points in my random subspace out of 2 to
the n total
uh and then i can raise it to the b
because i'm assuming all of these points
are linearly independent and so if i
take a random subspace the probability
that each of them is contained in this
subspace is
you know independent as a random
variable so i can just raise it to the b
okay so that's just equal to 2 to the
minus n minus k times b
if you didn't follow that it doesn't
really matter um but just i'm doing the
straightforward calculation of computing
the probability that a particular bad
set is in a random subspace
okay so now let's compute the expected
number of bad sets
in my random subspace so the expected
number of bad sets is just
the size of curly b the number of bad
sets times the probability that each one
of them lives in the subspace
great okay so now i can ask when is it
the case
that this expected number is little o of
one not like
that there's i expect there to be like
no uh
no bad sets in my random subspace well
you can just solve for it like if i want
this thing to be
um small then basically what i want is
that k divided by
n should be a bit less than 1 minus
log of b divided by b n so that's just
what happens when i
set this thing equal to 1 and solve for
it and then solve for k over n
right and then if we back off by that
additionally by some epsilon
we conclude that the probability that
there exists a bad set
um that's contained in my subspace is by
markov's inequality at most the expected
number of bad sets contained in my
subspace
which by plugging this thing into that
thing
is going to be at most 2 to the minus
epsilon n so very tiny
cool okay um does this make sense
great um cool so let's call this
threshold
let's call this value here um let's call
this the expectation threshold of curly
b
our expectation of of curly b um so
basically this is the threshold on
the ratio k over n dimension of the
subspace divided by dimension of the
ambient space
sort of above which you expect there to
be lots of bad sets in my subspace you
know a little omega of one bad sets
and below which you expect there to be a
little o of one bad sets in my subspace
so there's some threshold there
cool okay so getting back to our
question of like what is this threshold
what have we just learned so we've just
decided that by markov's inequality
there's this very easy to compute
threshold right here this expectation
threshold so if i back off by epsilon
it's really really likely that i avoid
all of the bad sets
and the question that we might be asking
at this point is well
is is this the right threshold like is
it the case that
the curve ought to finish off by doing
that um
or might it be the case that i could i
could go a little bit past that and the
threshold is something else
um intuitively like what it would mean
if if this were the case like
this would mean that the expectation the
expected number of bad sets in v is
really big
but the probability that there exists a
bad set in b is really small so this
might happen for example if
um there are some subspaces v that
contain tons and tons of bad sets but
most of them don't contain any
right that would that would be
consistent with um you know curves that
looks like this
or another way to say that is like once
a subspace v avoids one bag set it's
sort of pretty naturally likely to avoid
a bunch of other bad sets these things
are sort of these events are sort of
clustered in the subspaces
so this is the question we have like is
this the right threshold or is it
something else
question makes sense so
there is this uh was i don't know if it
still is a conjecture of khan and kalai
right that
the true threshold is i guess for every
monotone property
some log factor times
expectation threshold
that that is that a reasonable intuition
to have in this context as well i think
they might have said that in the context
of random graphs
yeah so actually we're going to get
something very similar
to the sorts of things one can get in
random graphs
here um uh yeah okay so spoiler alert
the answer is this is not the right
threshold you can go a little bit beyond
because we're looking at very specific
properties and not just like any
monotone property we're gonna be able to
get
like much tighter uh characterization of
of what that is
um maybe after i finish saying what our
result is i will mention the
relationship
um the two like this sort of flavor of
random graph results because they are
very
similar in spirit um yeah it's a really
good question um but yeah i guess the
the short-term answer is that yes
definitely related because we're looking
at much more specific properties we're
going to be able to get like much more
specific
answers
cool okay so um okay so i guess i
spoiled that the answer is that uh
you can go a bit long beyond this and
let me show you an example of how that
can happen
um so here's just a simple like toy
example of how you can like go beyond
this expectation threshold how that
first moment
argument does not give the right answer
so suppose that my bad set b
is all of the coordinate wise
permutations of
this thing um so here uh
i have like three three vectors so i
have a
little b is equal to three and i'm
looking at
uh all of the vectors where a quarter of
the coordinates look like one
zero zero a quarter of the coordinates
look like one zero one a quarter look
like 0 1 0 and a quarter look like 0 1
1. and then just like look at all the
coordinate permutations sort of close
this under an orbit and like that's my
bad collection and i just want to know
what's the probability
that a random subspace avoids any triple
of vectors that looks like this
okay so we can do this computation and
we can figure out what this expectation
threshold is
so the size of curly b uh will it's
about four to the n
um roughly they're like four possible
choices for each
uh column here for each row here and i
get to pick n of them
and then okay it's not exactly right
because they all have to be exactly in
over four but
close enough so okay so there's curly b
has about four to the end things in it
um so then the expectation threshold
is going to be just plugging in what we
got when we did that computation from
the previous slide
1 minus the log base 2 of the size of b
divided by
3 times n which is roughly one third
using the fact that the size of b is
roughly four okay
um so that tells us that uh we have this
picture here
um if i back off by uh a little bit from
one third so look at subspaces of ray
of dimension a little bit less than n
over three i'm with really high
probability going to avoid
all of uh the triples that look like
this
okay now consider what happens
when i just ignore this third vector so
i'm going to look at
a different collection of bad sets this
collection is going to be curly b
prime that's just given by dropping the
third vector right so now i'm
saying my my new bad collection is all
pairs of vectors
uh basically they'd have n over two of
the coordinates that look like one zero
and the other n over two look like zero
one
scrambled up in some order
we can ask once again what is the
probability that a random subspace
avoids all of these guys
um using our first moment type of
calculation so let's just
do the same thing again now the size of
curly b
prime is like two to the n there are two
possible choices i get to choose seven
times
um so we can just compute this
expectation threshold
it's one minus the log base two of b
prime divided by 2n
here this is 2 now because uh there are
two things
and this is about a half which is
notably larger than a third
so what this means is that
if i back off from just a half by just a
little bit
then all of a sudden it becomes really
likely that a random subspace of rate
you know a half minus epsilon is going
to avoid all pairs
of points that look like this but in
particular if it avoids all pairs of
points that look like this then it's
certainly going to avoid all triples of
points
um so that means that
like even if i go all the way out to
here like well beyond this one-third
threshold
it becomes really likely that i will
satisfy my original triple property even
though this is like way beyond what that
expectation threshold was for the triple
property
so um going back to this slide the
answer to this question does this always
give the correct threshold is no
um in fact it can be the case that this
sort of thing happens
um that the expected number of bad sets
is small but the probability
or sorry that the expected number of bad
sets in my is large but the probability
that there's any bad set is still small
those can't happen
did that example make sense
cool okay um so
now i can sort of get on to our
characterization theorem um
so theorem here's the informal version
this example
is basically the only reason why that
first moment method is not the right
answer
um so this example is the only reason
that expectation threshold is not the
right threshold
so what do i mean by that um so what
went on in this example
we had some set that we are interested
in and we projected it down by like
forgetting one of the
one of the elements and we made this new
set b
prime um we observed that if v a
subspace
avoids b prime then it definitely also
avoids b
um and somehow the size of b prime ended
up being like smaller than you might
think
um so therefore by markov's inequality
you're more likely to avoid it than you
might think um
and thus going backwards i'm more likely
to avoid this original set than i might
think
and so i claimed that basically this is
the only thing that can be going on i i
need to generalize it just just a little
bit
um so let me write this projection here
not as just like dropping a thing but
i'm just going to write it as
multiplying by some projection matrix
and then i'm going to generalize just
just a smidge by replacing this
projection matrix with any old matrix
um and now this is actually as as
general as i need to be
like this is sort of the only reason
that the expectation threshold is not
the right
threshold is because there's some little
matrix a here that i can multiply by
to get some set curly b prime so that
curly b prime is smaller than you might
think
um or equivalently that the expectation
threshold for curly b prime is larger
than you might think
so a little bit more formally although i
guess still with um
pictures uh suppose that curly b is
a single orbit under coordinate
permutations then
the threshold rate r star is equal to
the maximum
over all matrices a so just take the um
i guess worst or best depending on whose
side you are let's say best
matrix a and look at the expectation
threshold of what happens when you take
your original set
curly b and you multiply it by uh
by that matrix a right and that's going
to give you the
the threshold that's for a single orbit
if you have a property that you're
interested in that can be characterized
as the union of orbits
under coordinate permutations uh then
you basically just look at the worst
orbit
and that will give you the threshold so
do exactly the same thing for each orbit
and look at the worst of them
so that's the theorem statement sort of
for the characterization of this
threshold
are there any questions at this point
do you have some characterization of
when you don't need an a
to project down um
do you mean like when i can just use a
coordinate projection or when i don't
need
i don't need anything at all when the
expectation threshold is actually right
yeah yeah the latter oh um
that is a good question um so i guess i
can plug some recent work
uh with um venkat guru swami ray lee
jonathan mosheff nick resh and joshua
silas where we sort of apply these types
of techniques not to random subspaces
but just do completely random sets
and in that case you can actually show
that like you don't even need um
then the expectation threshold is kind
of exactly right um
for random subspaces
uh it's a good question i don't have a
good answer
um i will think about it
other questions
i think at this point i have a hidden
slide which um
addresses one of prasad's earlier
questions
uh which is the analogy to random graphs
so let me
um somehow it stopped showing my screen
when i went to hidden
yeah they uh i checked quickly they
oh in the end fractional expectation
threshold
this is what something taller grant had
mentioned
okay um yeah i'm not i'm not familiar
with the work
in particular that that you mentioned
but here's sort of like
something in general to like uh connect
this to
results of a similar flavor that are
proof for random graphs like
uh the type of statement that you might
be able to make um
for random graphs is that like you might
ask like when is h some subgraph h like
likely to appear as a subgraph of gnp
and the answer is like when p is large
enough so that for every subgraph of h
prime has an expectation omega of one
copies in g and this is um
basically an analogous statement to that
like when is a
particular bad set or bad collection b
earthly phase if it's a single orbit
likely to appear in a random subspace v
um it's when the dimension of v is large
enough so that every
like linear or i should say linear
projection
uh curly b prime of b has an expectation
omega of one copies in v so it's very
similar flavor to the
types of statements from random graphs
so hopefully that answers some questions
um
cool okay so uh i guess let me
oh i only have 10 minutes left or if
when do i when should i stop talking
yeah you have 10 to 15 minutes depending
since we are interrupting you
asking questions you can go until 5-2
this
sounds good um well hopefully uh uh i
will be able to wrap up in
uh 10 or 15 minutes or so problem so now
we've done through the main meet
um yeah so uh the proof of this
statement i'm actually not going to talk
about it which is why i will be able to
wrap up in 10 or 15 minutes
um it's it's not so hard actually it's
just a second moment method
um i direct you to the paper for the
details but i think really the hard part
is coming up with the right thing to
look at which in this case is these sort
of orbits under permutations and these
linear projections
and once you kind of know that that's
what you're going for and you know
you're supposed to use the second
moment method um it kind of works out
um so i'll direct you to the paper for
the proof but yeah basically just the
second moment method
okay so in the last part of the talk the
remaining 10 10 or 15 minutes or so
i want to talk about applications of
this characterization
um so i'm going to mention three
applications then only talk about one of
them
so the first application which i've
mentioned before is the list of
codability of random ldpc codes
um there are two other applications um
uh which um i'd point you to um this
paper
um for for these two uh this is joint
that's joint work with uh bangkok or
swami rayleigh jonathan mosheff nick
rush and joshua silas
um and there we can sort of use this
characterization to actually study
random linear codes themselves and get
better bounds on the number of points
that are likely to live in any ball or
in any combinatorial rectangle um
but for now i want to focus on this this
first point the list decodability of
random ldpc codes and so let me say
a little bit by what i mean about that
okay so
uh what what is an ldpc code so ldpc
stands for low density
parity check codes um so basically like
going back to that coding theory jargon
that i
brought up at the beginning the idea is
the following like suppose instead of
just taking a random subspace you take a
subspace that is the kernel
of a random sparse matrix sort of random
according to a particular distribution
um we consider something called
gallagher's ensemble of ldpc codes this
is a very
like classical distribution of sparse
matrices
defined in the 60s and the reason people
look at these sorts of things is that if
you're
using such a subspace for communication
so each point in this subspace
corresponds to a message that you want
to send
um then like you know if you receive a
perturbed version of this
point you want to be able to round back
quickly
and it turns out that if you're if the
subspace that you're looking at is a
uniformly random subspace then this is
conjectured to be an extremely difficult
problem
however if the subspace that you're
looking at is the kernel of some sparse
matrix and it turns out that there are
efficient algorithms to do this so
there's very fast
that's called unique decoding algorithms
and for this reason ldpc codes are
ubiquitous in both
theory and practice so it would be
really cool if we could like extend
these results
for uniformly random subspaces to uh
these sorts of subspaces which are not
uniformly random they're much more
structured
in particular the question that we were
interested in is are these things list
decodable
so that was the question of like are
there too many points that's contained
in any hannibal
um right so the math question here is
instead of a uniformly random v you have
uh this structured
random subspace so the kernel of some
sparse matrix
um i'm going to just call this subspace
in a random ldpc code
and i want to know what's the
probability that no l points of v are
contained in any hamming ball of radius
p
n so that's the question
okay and so here's a theorem uh that
answers this question
um suppose you have some b local
property um
like listed codability we've already
looked at um let epsilon be greater than
zero
and suppose that a random subspace of
dimension
r times n satisfies this property with
high probability
right so uh in the the picture that we
had here
like what if we know that a random
subspace a uniformly random subspace is
going to have a picture that looks like
this
so if a random subspace satisfies uh
this property with high probability that
means that r is a little bit less than
some r star so we're in this regime over
here then the conclusion of the theorem
is that a random ldpc code
of dimension a little bit less uh also
satisfies that property with high
probability
so that is we can sort of bring the the
positive part of this curve
uh just bring that to random ldpc codes
so the probability that a k-dimensional
ldpc code
satisfies this property is also high
so a useful corollary of this is that
random lppc codes
are list decodable sort of okay so some
jargon
up to list decoding capacity so
basically there's been a long line of
work
um which establishes that
random linear codes aka uniformly random
subspaces
have basically optimal trade-offs for
this how many points live in a ball
uh type of question and now for free we
get those
results translated to these much more
structured codes
so this is the theorem i want to say a
few words about the
proof but are there any questions about
the statement
so this is a one-sided statement
uh uh you mean like
like the picture i only have a purple
line here and i don't extend it down
there
uh yeah that's right yeah so this is a
one sided statement
um it's a really good question whether
the converse is true
um so actually the converse is false um
but it's false for stupid reasons
uh kind of the for this particular
ensemble of
ldpc codes for like for this particular
ensemble of random matrices
like you can set up the parameters so
that um
there are no odd weight vectors that
live in this kernel
if you set things up to be regular
enough with your sparsity pattern then
you can
rule out odd weight odd weight vectors
appearing in the kernel
um but of course it's extremely likely
that an odd weight vector will appear in
a uniformly random subspace
um so that uh will kind of break like
that silly example kind of breaks
the converse but um it seems plausible
that
uh you can formulate some kind of
converse that
rules out like silly sort of
divisibility
uh things like that um yeah i i i do
think that converse is true just you
have to like rule out certain
certain bad cases yeah
great question uh other questions
cool okay so let me say just a little
bit about the the proof
um so i claim that this basically comes
for free from this characterization that
i just told you
um so here's why okay so first we need a
lemma
so the lemma is the following so subject
to some
fine print the probability
that a particular bad set b
is contained in a random ldbc code so
that is the kernel of this sparse
random sparse matrix according to this
particular distribution
is approximately 2 to the minus
1 minus epsilon times n minus k times b
where this epsilon here
um depends on the the sparsity of the
matrix and some other things
um and the thing that's notable about
this is that
this is basically the same as for a
random linear code or sorry for a
uniformly random subspace
right before we when we did this
computation for a uniformly random
subspace
we just like uh it wasn't didn't have
this one minus epsilon but
just everything else was exactly the
same so
intuitively that means that um okay so
if if curly b
is unlikely to appear in a uniformly
random subspace
then what we just showed in this
characterization theorem is that
essentially there's like a first moment
reason why that is true
um right essentially there's some uh
projection a um
that that gives you some some smaller
like curly b
prime so that girly curly b prime uh
just by markov's inequality won't appear
um
but then that same first moment
reasoning is going to apply to random
ldpc codes
because we just showed that this uh or
i just stated that um the probability
that any particular bad stat is
contained in a random ldpc code
is basically the same as for a uniformly
random code um so any sort of first
moment argument you want to make markups
inequality expectations stuff like that
is going to work
just the same for an ldpc code as it
does for a uniformly random code
so that means that this reason here like
there exists this b
prime such that blah blah blah you can
still make that argument for the random
ldpc code it goes through just the same
so then we conclude that curly b is also
unlikely to be in a random ldbc code
or like i said in more detail we'd
conclude that curly b prime is not going
to be in this random ldbc code and then
therefore curly b is not either
um so this just goes immediately from
that
um so how do we prove the lemma uh
just i guess some some real quick
intuition um
like the probability that a particular
bad set b
is contained in a random ldpc code um
this is the same as the probability of b
times this sparse random matrix is equal
to zero that all of these columns
of b uh are contained in the kernel of
this matrix right so here i'm
viewing a bad set as a matrix thinking
of the columns of this matrix as the the
elements of my bad set
so all of these things being in the code
is the same as when i multiply by this
uh
called a parity check matrix i'm going
to get 0.
okay so let's focus in on just one row
of this
like what does it mean for one row of
this thing to be zero basically it means
that for
sort of a random subset of rows of this
matrix b
the ones that are picked out by these
ones uh in the matrix
that those are going to add to zero um
and
in the particular distribution that
we're looking at these ones are sort of
random enough
that uh you could basically use some
foray analytic
argument um to show that uh you know
provided that
um this set b is uh not too pathological
then if i take a sum of a bunch of rows
the probability that that sum of a bunch
of random rows is zero
is about what it should be which is like
two to the minus b
um and then you have this little one
minus epsilon fudge factor which depends
on the number of random rows you take
this works as long as uh i guess the
columns of b aren't too close together
or actually
it should be that nothing in the span of
the columns of b are too close together
um but it turns out that we can sort of
rule out that bad
case separately um it's well known that
ldpc codes have
good distance which in particular means
that none of the things in it are going
to be too close together so
you can ignore those other bees and for
all the rest of them this sort of uh
basic argument that if you take a bunch
of random things it's kind of going to
even out
works pretty well cool
okay so that's um basically all i'm
gonna say uh about the
proof of this theorem um but again the
corollary is that
uh these results that people have
sweated very hard to prove for uniformly
random
codes now come just sort of kind of for
free for more structured ensembles
like random ldpc codes okay
so let me wrap up quickly so just to
recap
um i started out the talk by asking like
what
local properties are satisfied by random
subspaces
um there's a whole bunch of local
properties that you might be interested
in from the context
of error correcting codes and maybe
there's some other local properties that
you're interested in
i told you that theorem local properties
have sharp thresholds for any local
property there's some r star
below which you're very likely to
satisfy the property above which are
very likely not to satisfy the property
i told you that this threshold has a
nice characterization basically this
first moment approach is almost right
just with one
little tweak um and uh
in particular that gives us some
applications uh to list decoding random
ldpc codes
basically allowing us to um say well if
the first moment's all you need well
at least we have the first moment stuff
for random ldpc codes so let's just do
that
um so that allows us to translate these
results
cool okay so let me conclude with just a
couple of open questions
um the main open question i think is
what what are some other applications of
this characterization
um so i mentioned uh three and and
discussed one in in detail
um but all of these applications are to
error correcting codes because that's
what i think about most of the time so
i'm sure
maybe this audience would have different
ideas of applications and i would love
to hear them
um and the other big open question uh
is algorithms for list decoding ldpc
codes
so my motivation for studying ldpc codes
was that they have efficient algorithms
they have efficient algorithms
for unique decoding um that's when i
happen to know that there's only
one point in the ball um but
if i want to say you you give me the
center of a hamming ball and i'm
supposed to tell you
all of the points in this subspace that
live in that having ball efficiently
um you know ideally in linear time uh
i i don't know how to do that um so what
we've shown is that it's at least
uh in principle possible like there's
not an exponential number of
an exponential number of points you have
to return but actually coming up with an
algorithm uh i think is a
really nice open question okay um so i
think
that's it so with that i will uh stop
talking and
take any more questions that you have
thank you thanks very much let's uh
clap any questions
any more questions i should say
i have a couple but i'll hold on
uh for the for the b local property uh
it
is invariant under all permutations is
it
would it work if it was invariant under
like a
subgroup of uh permutations um
that's a good question uh
or just if you if you have like some
symmetry but not like the full
uh yeah yeah so the reason we need the
symmetry
is um
basically the way the way the the proof
goes is we kind of break things
into these orbits and kind of study them
orbit by orbit
uh and then it's it's very easy to get a
handle
on the number of things in that orbit if
you just if it's just all the
permutations um
i think that
yeah so i haven't thought about it um it
feels like something should
still go through uh if you have some
other symmetry groups that you're
looking at
um but yeah i haven't thought of it is
there is there a particular application
that you have in mind for why
why that would come up no no just i i
guess i i
could imagine situations where you you
don't have to follow the symmetries but
you still want to have a sharp version
yeah
um that's a good question uh yeah i
don't know the answer off the top of my
head i
i my gut says that maybe something
should the idea should basically go
through but i haven't tried it
so the characterization itself is that
if uh
you have this sharp threshold as long as
you don't contain such a
property right something that's
that's bounded by b and converi
that's right yeah yeah yeah so um
so i i didn't want to ask this earlier
because i thought i might confuse
everybody
so the you know being familiar with the
hood fried goods theorem uh
and about sharp threshold um
in the context of random graphs random
structures
um so the way i think about it is that
basically any global property
is expected to have it's a sharp
threshold in
in the senses you know that people
define in random graphs
um so that's why here it confused me
too just the terminology oh right
this is a local property yeah yeah
that's
intuition is that if they're like you
know not con
not containing a triangle or a fixed uh
finite list of fixed subgraphs and so on
so
um just the terminology yeah
yeah yeah but the other difference i
think a more uh
to me a more important difference seems
to be of course the models are different
there you have sort of full independence
by picking each edge
independently and so on um
[Music]
so but there uh the notion of sharp
threshold is also a bit different right
so
you measure uh you measure the slope
of this curve with respect to where it
happens
so you look at sort of right you you see
the r star so to speak
right p star the probability where you
expect the
uh the property uh typically the
monotone or anti-you know
non-mono sorry um
it's gone from one to zero so the
anti-monotone property
where it goes from one minus epsilon to
epsilon
so you put yourself at one half let's
say
and then you ask yourself how sharp is
the threshold
uh but here
you don't define it that way right
that's right yeah i guess maybe we're
looking at sort of a less refined
version of thresholds um we're just
saying like
go epsilon in this direction it should
be i guess in the slides i just said one
minus little o of one but it's
right right one minus two to the minus
epsilon n um
yeah the sort of thing uh but
yeah we're just sort of looking like
what is this we're more interested in
what what is the threshold
rather than the um the exact same but
yeah it's an interesting question
um yeah the final one seems actually
quite a bit many years ago at microsoft
john
kim and i spent some time trying to work
with the
finer notion and you know even to prove
things like if i start picking vectors
of weight
k uh you know can i show that there's a
sharp threshold as to when i
lose uh independence right at some point
i go from being independent to deepen
yeah uh
turned out to be quite non-trivial but i
think this this looks like
actually a nice uh set of results
uh which maybe gives hope to attack the
finer
sense of thresholds yeah as someone
who's thought
um a lot about like random subspaces and
like when you have
these sorts of results i guess mostly
from the context of coding theory uh
somehow this
way of thinking about it um feels feels
more right to me than than previous ways
of like breaking it up into these sort
of
orbits under permutations and uh
yeah i'm hopeful that there are going to
be other applications of this framework
as well so if there are questions about
random subspaces that
are still nagging you uh i would love to
hear more about them sure
but i just posted in the chat the link
to this paper i was referring to oh
awesome thank you that was uh yeah
um any other questions folks
i i had a small question about the
about the the amount of randomness so
um yeah you assume it's a uniformly
randomized subspace
uh do you need that much independence or
let's say i mean if it has size b is the
b wise independence sufficient for the
proof to go through
or even less what uh um
yeah good question
um i mean so in some sense the the third
part of the talk is almost like
de-randomizing
this result is saying like instead of
looking at a uniformly random subspace
you're looking at the kernel of a much
more structured matrix so that uses a
lot less randomness
in terms of
whether such a threshold result would
hold if you just had
bui's independence or something
i don't see or like i don't i don't see
why
not right now or two maybe two b wise
independence for the second moment
method
they need to look at pairs of them um
but i'm probably missing something silly
uh
good question
um yeah i'll uh
yeah i don't know off the top of my head
i don't see right now what
would break um i guess one one thing is
that
we might be able to uh all right so now
i know i'm like
going on a limb because i haven't
thought about whether or not this is
true but if that is true
it might be that then you could prove
this sharp threshold theorem
but unfortunately you couldn't
understand where the threshold
was so like these other results of like
when is a uniformly random subspace list
decodable
those results definitely do not work
with limited independence
um and so those are the results that
we're kind of like harnessing and then
we're using this characterization
theorem to like bring those through
so if you were to start with a limited
randomness thing
um like it might be that we wouldn't be
able to get a very good handle on the
thresholds
uh to begin with um
but maybe it would prove that they're
worth sharp thresholds i don't know if
that answer made sense
yeah thank you
any more discussion or questions
if not uh let's thank mary again and uh
also there's the gather town link omid
that shared with us
earlier so feel free to continue um
discussion there thanks again mary nice
nice thanks everyone for watching
bye good to see you again bye bye